art is possible all right Long Island
miss connections which I've been told
are so Long Island it's unbelievable I
hop you were my server at IHOP in comic
first of all comic is such a [ __ ]
like Long Island sounding [ __ ]
[ __ ] tall brunette now I want you to
hop on me so [ __ ] clever you were my
server at IHOP in carmack tall brunette
now I want you to hop on me Oh [ __ ]
poet dude you got poets in Long Island
oh I didn't realize there were poets in
Long Island until I read these [ __ ]
misconnections huh I hop you were my
server at IHOP and Carmack 12 brunette
now I want you to hop on me did not
contact me with unsolicited services or
office the [ __ ] subject of this one
or the the title of this one free Taco
Bell at 1:00 a.m. poor Jeff station the
fact that the name Jeff is in there
anyway
anywhere is hilarious I just pulled up
to the drive-thru and told you and you
told me you waited an hour to get your
food and they gave you a [ __ ] load so if
you offered me some shitload of it so
you offered me some you in a black SUV
and you said you worked at a restaurant
do not contact me once those were dude
if you're trying to hit on a girl
don't ever say [ __ ] load that's like
saying heaps you ever talk to a [ __ ]
Australian guy like oh yeah heaps yeah
heaps
I'll lock your heaps you know oh [ __ ]
dried up you
be drinking a [ __ ] bottle water go
back to keep it then you go to bar
drinking a bottle of water
it'd be like lucky hi how's it going and
the girls are psycho who I'm so into you
and you're drinking a bottle of water oh
lucky heaps weird the fact of me water
God where the [ __ ] did my water guy oh
you said heaps and it dried up all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and even the water dried
up
they got empty bottle now if your truck
dude if you say I do it I just [ __ ]
like it I like a girl I'd like to take
you out you know we can go somewhere get
a shitload of food by the first time
effectively no you have to do something
about it because there's anybody need
any help you know you're the only one
that guy just said you like he likes me
a shitload and I drove away and got an
accident
I'll be right back with your coffee I'll
be right back with your coffee why this
song [ __ ] wrists do
[ __ ] with the guitar imagine playing
this live
what is that even in there but before I
love how they tried to make it rip more
the song already rips the song already
ribs dude and they try to [ __ ] rock
around when I first saw the first
mission impossible and they made that
[ __ ] song with time I was I go I was
in the theater out loud I literally girl
I guess
oh of course I already knew it was gonna
sound like and it did dude [ __ ] yeah
dude
I [ __ ] to this I make love to this
every time every single time I [ __ ] it
is I made a kid um okay what's the next
one
one Janis Oh is there a more name that's
[ __ ] what do you call it then Janis
more Long Island than Janis
maybe no there's not honestly you know
her hair looks like wondering what
happened to you Janis used to see you
driving up the block it's kind of Boston
I can't get away from it I was a
neighbor a few houses down did you move
I don't see you anymore hey know your
neighbors hey guy
she didn't [ __ ] you didn't know her
cuz she didn't because you creeped her
out dude do not contact me unsolicited
services or offers you know Janis do it
every time Janis draw by she was like oh
there's that [ __ ] creep do not
contact anyone solicitor property yeah
here's no one you cut my hair should
know her you cut my hair Saturday
morning you commented on my gold chain
to hood Long Island I would like to get
to know you and thank you for a
fantastic haircut do nothing that New
York the most New York word is fantastic
for real you think it's not what it is
osmanthus Nick oh yeah you have a pizza
at [ __ ] John's it's fantastic you get
the fantastic dough your [ __ ] whip it
around it's [ __ ] fantastic man you
ever try to [ __ ] lumix cameras
they're fantastic
and they get a shot like no other you
never see a [ __ ] yeah I never see a
[ __ ] you never see a [ __ ] shot
like this you're waiting zooming in and
out it's [ __ ] fantastic
you ever see the walls over at the
[ __ ] Museum fantastic unbelievable
swear to God that Lake over there
[ __ ] you ever been a master pika it's
fantastic it's beautiful it's [ __ ]
fantastic they got like two three months
of the year fantastic the other month's
also fantastic but I'm just saying